red's right-hander luis castillo his
numbers chris from western and southern
well those are his overall numbers but i
got to think that inside luis castillo's
head is still a little bit of payback
because opening day was not very kind to
him
here's a check swinging ball four high
tommy edmond fell behind against
castillo and works a walk goldsmith has
gone eight for 32 with a double two
homer six rbis facing luis castillo
tommy edmond the runner at first base
one ball then two strikes and goldie
hammers one
deep right castianos looks up gone
opposite field home run number 22 for
paul goldsmith two to nothing cardinals
here in game one
he now is driven in 79
and the cardinals jump out on top john
lester the lefty is on the mound for st
louis it's a big gap in left center
field the ball flies during the summer
there is bader racing over in left
center to make the catch but it is
definitely short and right and right
center field for sure
payoff
down and castellanos walks
john lester's gonna have to do
there's a swing and a miss and a
strikeout avato the first of the night
for lester
here it is and yeti swings striking out
there's the change up right at the
bottom threshold of the zone three
straight strikeouts for luis castillo
farmer since the all-star break is hit
309
and that one is socked and deep left
kyle farmer
connects on a line drive homer and the
reds on the board
so there's the mvp award and there's the
unsung
mvp
there he is right there just solid
in every phase of the game
and he strikes him out on 99 dotted up
in the way
3-2 again and he walked him second walk
by castillo and it brings in dylan
carlson
goldschmidt held on india a short right
ground ball
farmer calls off india with the tip of
the glove and makes the play
3-2 pitch
got him that time
second strikeout for jon lester the 2-2
pitch
ground ball
orinato
and just got him 404 to straight away
center 370 and right and 325 down the
right field line swinging a hard hit
ball base hit past the third baseman
suarez so good at back by uh nolan
arenado
ground ball up the middle india hits the
bag on the first double play
and castillo is saving his best up for
molina
lester has his sign from molina and here
comes the 3-2 delivery and that's swung
out and missed
breaking ball
lifted in the air to shallow right
sliding catch dylan carlson two away it
was scary right there that ball looked
like it was in no man's land theo
already in 70 pitches
does get swinging to miss
seven strikeouts for castillo
with the fly ball shallow left aquino
coming on and it drops and bader on his
way to second base and a good play from
the shortstop farmer to go out on that
ball and hold bader to two
to short farmer
[Applause]
and the ground ball gets castillo and
company out of it funny it's tough
sometimes to see with that black bat
and a swing and a miss goes back out
there again
lester to aquino ground ball off
lester's glove to the shortstop and sosa
throws him out
the slider away the pitch by castillo a
fastball and that swung on and missed
that was in the dirt
here for cincinnati 3-2 pitch and
carlson rips it into right field extra
bases
it's a pretty swing right there
down target
backhand fare suarez the throw runner
breaks bottom fire farmer on the cover
no chance at a tag with o'neal up two
outs runner at third pitch count at an
even 100 they're playing back at third
that's suarez dylan carlson can get down
the line softly hit that'll score a run
in an infield hit for tyler o'neill to
make it 3-1 cardinals
talked about the four seamers like every
now and then you can surprise a guy with
a four-seamer because it's not gonna
sink sosa bare hands and got him and
mundo sosa do or die with the bare hand
charging in
and he gets that's druval cabrera great
play
3-2 again
the high fly ball into center backing up
bader with rome
first look at the cardinals
the numbers he's had so far with the
reds only one walk in 10 and a third
lester a base hit and now here comes a
two run homer by tommy edmond
india
nice sliding stop from benton
nice play
and the 1-2 pitch
curveball again had him out in front
shallow right center
vader there
3-1
missed off the plate
and the second walk by lester
john lester
six and a third
he has struck out five walked one and
allowed one base hit that was the cow
farmer home run in the second that is it
it's been great tonight
tj mcfarland has been huge for the
cardinals very very good pitch yesterday
21 pitches chevy call to the pin
walks bases loaded walks step into issue
farmer shoots this one down the left
field line fair ball
and bottle has to stop as it skips
kyle farmer another extra base hit
the 2-1
ground ball left side arenado backhands
to the plate and the out and it stays
3-1 and there's two away
in an easy play there for nolan arnotto
his vato is off with contact if you want
to strike out you got to go up
outside corner mcfarland cleans it up
the seventh to score this inning hoffman
trying to make it a scoreless eighth
orinato
a two-hit knight with a base hit to left
and a pitch elevated
he was ready for it shortly at first by
nolan aronado and a 2-1 pitch to tyler
o'neill
and that is a base hit into center
ornato to third base runners at the
corners for the cardinals and it brings
in yadier molina two hit night tyler
o'neal
desperate to keep it a two-run deficit
swinging a mass chasing in a ball
downstairs
[Applause]
india is on
tying run bats here in the eighth
fly ball
center field
vader
for the reds and they'll face a man who
has blown a save seven times in nine
tries on the year the one two
he got him with the breaking pitch that
time and a strikeout of vato
the 2-2
popped him up
this should do it so some
he's under it and has it the cardinals
take game one by the final of three to
one
[Applause]